probably like an 85% chance that I might
throw up after this mm-hmm I love
sriracha the question for me is like
what don't I put sriracha on salads
soups burgers some things people think
are weird I'm game to try I am NOT an
adventurous person when it comes to food
I feel excited and nervous I'm nervous
as hell yeah bring that money there's a
hot-ass dummy beer yes yes this is what
I'm talking about it tasted like a
Hawaiian pizza I could take another bite
of this the clear one not that bad not
bad weird Oh God okay Cheers
I can't find any redeeming qualities
about this sandwich oh this is so good
I'm innocent home know what I'm okay
with this surprisingly not terrible this
is the best thing that I've actually
ever had it I'm not even kidding
oh sweet Oh yep so okay this is actually
food this is great yeah my regards to
the [ __ ] okay let's do that all right
let's do it
hmm
[Music]
it's infiltrating every part of my life
and I'm okay with it honestly it makes
me believe in love again so you didn't
throw anything weird on here like banana
oh thanks guys thank you I'm gonna name
my firstborn sriracha don't do that I'm
proud to be an American and I'm proud to
be a sriracha lover yeah good